[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
[Rires]
voilà fous rires de bébé pour démarrer
la journée moi je dis que rien ne plus
d'électricité et vous l'entendez il ya
une sirène qui retentit en ce moment
pour l'instant il n'y a pas beaucoup de
voitures on n'y a pas énormément on va
pas dire qu'il ya une fuite massive des
civils alors où on se parle depuis la
place maïdan même si effectivement vous
l'entendez la sirène retentit et donc
effectivement et bien kiev qui se
réveille ce matin bombardées alors même
qu hier soir c'était absolument pas le
l'idée générale ici à kiev c'est donc la
guerre et nous entrons ce matin dans un
autre monde la dmr poutine change
aujourd'hui le cours de l'histoire la
guerre aux portes de l'europe la guerre
après la pandémie la guerre à laquelle
personne ne voulait croire
la russie gens ne le prend le pas je
prends le pari n'envahira pas lui créer
on va voir ce qui se passe depuis la
fenêtre de la chambre on va rester avec
vous clémence et sirènes qui
retentissent c'est des sirènes pour
annoncer un bombardement
à la ferme et elle a bouclé la fenêtre
qu'elle s'est mise à l'abri se met à
l'abri elle se met elle se met en
sécurité dont vous vous étiez vous vous
étiez avocat gb vous avez rencontré de
la dîmière poutine parce qu'au départ il
vous interrogez c'est ça oui là c'est
notre première rencontre avec ce connard
vraiment awacs et oui c'est un connard
je l'aï bernard guetta voulait justement
norbourg messieurs c'est ma
part dont pierre servant on continue si
vous le voulez bien j'ai pris la
décision d'une opération militaire
spéciale à ceux qui tenteraient
d'interférer avec nous il doit savoir
que la réponse de la russie sera
immédiate et conduira à des conséquences
que vous n'avez encore jamais connu et
juin unique à la mi temps on s'y
attendait pas mais christiane taubira
comme à son habitude a guère car hélas
guère à poutine mais aussi à
l'orthographe regardez voilà ce qu'est
la wii monsieur poutine
qu'est ce qui vous attend dès
aujourd'hui de la communauté européenne
du soutien international
et vous qu'est ce que votre vie vous
pouvez faire pour éviter que la guerre
soit chez vous d'ici quelques mois
peut-être même quelques jours même
quelques semaines qu'est ce qu'est ce
que vous faites qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire n'oublions pas vous parle
aujourd'hui ne l'oublions pas les
souffrances que nous avons infligées par
des inférieur d intervention militaire
sans moi je vous parle des souffrances à
cet instant même l'armée de poutine est
en train d'infliger ne les aggraveront
pas aussi villes d'ukraine la réponse
militaire les aggravera conduire
conduire à vladimir poutine ont renchéri
re restait encore clara
session ça mon compte est de restaurer
dans ces moments de tension incidemment
et je ne crois pas que la posture sur
des plateaux de télévision soit la bonne
réponse mais écoutez je suis heureux de
vous l'entendre dire parce que je vous
voilà dans une posture merci me semble
pas de la vie dure mais ce musée la
situation où on vous réconciliera pas ce
soir merci dominique de villepin d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir se limite à peu de
frais va la marche militaire
[Musique]
je veux pas dire qu'il est fou parce que
s'il est fou il est responsable ça veut
dire qu'il est il ne se composerait
voilà il est dans sa logique et je veux
pas lui enlever la spawn la
responsabilité je dis qu'ils perdent les
pédales mais il est pas fou d'accord
donc mais bon oui lui pourrait avoir
recours à la matière comme vous l'avez
dit il à la moitié de l'arsenal
nucléaire la planète et dakhla ce qui se
passerait la fin du monde qui a fait son
temps
décédé à bâle à il a fait son temps ça
c'est sûr payez maintenant tu sert plus
à rien
il a fait son temps ça lui
a fait le travail à main des familles
ouais et papa du coup c'est plutôt quoi
son travail lui qui y seraient libres
c'est ça qu'est ce qui fait il les rend
comment non je
n'y peux rien retour sur cette journée
qui a sidéré l'europe et le monde entier
paul rémy barjavel et christophe rockets
bon alors
alors il va repartir dans quelques
instants et l'a voulu être espions donc
elles étaient situées en dehors of sales
et il s'est passé un truc que mon
éditeur n'a jamais voulu maintenant dans
le livre donc en fait il est entré à
leningrad à l'époque il avait un petit
copain et sa femme il y avait sa femme
qui était qui portait son enfant son
futur enfant et au lieu de voir sa femme
il est allé voir son copain ah oui non
mais les défenseurs votre corps
désinhibés par les quelques verres de
vodka le jeune garçon du gers se lance
dans une déclaration d'amour à ses hôtes
moi j'en veux vous dire que je vous aime
je ne comprenais pas ça ça restera
longtemps dans ma tête tout le monde
ahmat
symbio merci j'ai vraiment l'impression
d'être la maison et d'être est là avec
micro ping et de boire l'apéro ils se
sont promenés aller à saint pétersbourg
ils étaient dans la rue il ya des gens
le plus de la russie fin père homophobe
donc il ya des gens qui les ont marqués
il s'est battu ça finit au commissariat
et du commissariat c'est remonté à
moscou et on lui a dit fini tu veux tu
seras jamais plus espions et donc on a
envoyé un ivrogne intrigue c'est glee
qui recouvrira mon tatouage gagnera son
poids en zig net et ça c'est dur
c'est en
danger le 9 septembre c'est ça c'est ça
mais
moi j'adore ces petits soucis sont là
j'en mange toujours temps plein mais je
savais pas que j'étais une addict et les
iguanes est à se connaître plein les
dents comment ça va ta vie de la très
bien bruno cette petite partie de chasse
avant de venir ça s'est bien passé et à
biarritz 22 fringues c'est nul je suis
désolé on a dit pas les vêtements pas
les mères enfin quand même
recevoir qu'au niveau fringues c'est pas
là où vous mettez ou plusieurs genres
non j'ai d'autres sources de dépenses
mais quand on a la chance d'avoir un
corps de rêve l'emballage
[Musique]
c'est bien pour nous c'est ça les grands
avocats ils ont réponse à tout valérie
pécresse était hier l'invité de bfm tv
l'occasion pour la candidate de revenir
sur les soupçons de fraude lors de la
primaire et l'heure à laquelle je le
rappelle auraient voté un chien et des
morts fiable et voici le lapsus de la
semaine la vérité sur ce scrutin c'est
qu'il ya moins de gens qui étaient
inscrits que des gens qui ont pu voter
[Musique]